mon père était savetier mon grand-père
était savetier j'en ai hérité et j'ai
aimé ce métier par-dessus
tout voilà vous avez pu m'arranger ça
comme il fa oui oui oui je vous ai
refait vos talon en plastique durci au
smelleinttérieur que j'ai changé en
bazane et puis alors toutes ces petites
coutures à la main que nous avons refait
là parce que ça ça lchane un petit peu
tous les bouts voilà je dois combien
euh 34 F monsieur vous Perrez la semaine
prochaine vous me les donnez comme ça
[Applaudissements]
d'accord monsieur martinau vous êtes
SAFTI ou coordonni safetier ce que je
fais là c'est ça relève du métier de
safetier cordonnier veut dire vente de
chaussures neuves et non pas réparation
mais tous les cordonniers de Paris sont
des
réparateurs oui mais c'est une fausse
appellation on s'est toujours appelé
Cordonier alors qu'en réalité nous
sommes savetier qui veut dire réparateur
de vieille savat il y a combien de temps
faites ce
métier 40
ans quand on choisit un métier comme ça
c'est parce qu'on
l'aime
mon père était savetier mon grand-père
était savetier j'en ai hérité et j'ai
aimer ce métier par-dessus
tout en 1292 on compté à Paris 226
cordonniers et 140 savetiers les
premiers travaillant exclusivement le
cuir neuf les seconds le cuir
usager mais il se corrél souvent
excéd Louis X promulg en 1767 par lettre
patente un statut commun au de corps
d'état depuis lors cordonniers et
savetiers travaillent indifféremment le
vieux et le
[Applaudissements]
neuf
là on a l'impression que vous abîmez une
chaussure plutôt que de la réparer et
non pas du tout c'est une incision qu'on
fait dans le cuir qui s'appelle une
gravure qui est faite pour réserver
l'emplacement de la couture de façon
qu'ensuite on puisse rabattre ce cuir en
l'ANT encollé
par-dessus pour protéger le fil et qu'
ne s' pas rapidement c'est vousmême qui
faites la couture non non non non nous
faisons faire ça par des cousurs qui
nous cous nosommelag parce que c'est un
matériel bien trop important pour avoir
ça chez un cordonnier on ne fait plus de
couture à la main on ne fait plus de
couture à la main sauf chez certains
btiers mais chez le savetier c'est
terminé alors voyez ce que je fais c'est
pour consolider cette trapointe c'est
une mauvaise
fabrication juste fixé avec des agrafes
au lieu d'être tout loué comme je le
fais ou cousu comme c'est fait dans
certains certains fabricants
euh donc il faut absolument leur
consolider pour pouvoir fixer son
ressemelage dessus et ensuite être sûr
que cette trpointe ce qu'on appelle ce
liserette autour s'appelle une trpointe
sur lequelle s'appuie il va être cousu
le
[Musique]
ressemelage
voilà une opération qui ne se fait plus
guerre maintenant à notre époque étant
donné que nous disposons de machines à
coller des press alors qu'auparavant il
fallait environ donner 80 coups de
marteau par sem
ce qui fait que pour une paire ça en
faisait 160 si on en avait 10 ou 15
paires collé à la que le leu ça
représentait 1600 ou 1800 coups de
marteau à donné dans un minimum de temps
avec un marteau qui est très
lourd en
1560 dans la confrerie des savetiers de
reins le chefdœuvre de l'apprenti
consistait dans la réparation pleine et
entière de une paire de vieilles bottes
avec boucles et rosettes une paire de
bottines de Dam une paire de gros
souliers de vaches à simple semelle de
bois à l'usage des laboureur à la fin un
rapport était adressé au procureur du
Roi qui recevait alors le serment du
nouveau maître savetier moyennant une
lourde taxe et les frais d'un repas
collectif les femmes pouvaient également
tenir boutique pourvu qu'elles offrent
toute garantie d'honnêteté et de bonne
Meur madame
Martino le rôle d'une femme de Cordonier
est-il
important oui assez puisqu'il consiste
déjà à recevoir la clientèle à la
conseiller d'une part d'autre part la
femme doit faire le classement des
chaussures
faire également des travaux manuels tels
que les piqûes des glissoirs enfin ce
qu'on appelle les glissoirs c'est coudre
des pet à l'intérieur des contreforts
des chaussures usagé naturellement je
suis cordonnière de métier j'ai appris
mon métier je n'ai pas de cap à ce
momentl on ne parlait pas de cap puisque
je travaille depuis 35 ans mais en 35
ans la qualité
change Mo j'ai acheté ces bottes là je
voudrais bien que vous me les répariez
parce que elles sont abîmées oui bah
vous savez mis à part les talons et
encore qui sont en plastique ENF c'est
pas possible qu Mme et si le reste je ne
peux rien fairecoup mais non mais vous
avez payer la tige sans doute mais le
reste en dessous est irréparable rien de
colle dessus c'est une matière plastique
vous devez aller jusqu'au bout et
légeter je ne peux donc vous faire que
vos talons enfin c'est pas honnête
vis-à-vis de la maison ils auraient pu
dire pr c'est la mode actuelle on p très
cher maintenant mais c'est pas une
référence alors je vous fais que vos
talons c'est tout ce que je peux vous
faire bah tant pis qu'est-ce que vous
voulez voilà donc les talons actuels
et leur ennui pour la réparation étant
donné que dans le commerce nous ne
retrouverons pas des bonbouts tout près
qui sont faits exclusivement pour les
fabricants mais non pas pour le
réparateur étant donné qu'en plus il en
faudrait une énorme quantité dans la
taille dans les épaisseurs de cheville
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes obligés soit de comme vous pouvez
voir ces talons sont très creux j'
rentre le Doig les trous qui sont prévus
à côté sont aussi eux mêm très profonds
alors on est obligé de boucher avec des
chevilles de bois si c'est du calibre ou
bien avec la propre cheville d'origine
puisquelle est du même calibre alors
voyez par contre dans la mauvaise
chaussure aussi on a un remplissage ce
qu'on appelle du remplissage c'est pour
combler la différence de niveau entre la
tige qui vient s'arrêter ici à
l'intérieur et le trou que ça formerait
une fois la semelle posée et vous voyez
que ici en l'occurrence c'est une
matière un cinderme un genre de carton
alors que dans la bonne chaussure ça
doit être rempli en cuir on y trouve
même actuellement dans les chaussures de
femme à se Melle très épaisse juste la
petite bordure en cuir et tout
l'intérieur est rempli soit de ficell
pilé soit de plastique soit de gomme et
qui nous pose évidemment des problèmes
le jour où on les démonte parce que tout
nous vient dans les mains et on sait pas
quoi mettre pour remplacer ce
rempli un autre genre de talon qui est
lui normal tout en
bois mais d'un autre côté la cliente l'a
usé exagérément ce qui fait que pour
rattraper nous sommes obligés de
terminer et de finir notre talon à la
machine pour pouvoir le mettre à
niveau est-ce que vous avez des
apprentis non malheureusement d'une part
parce qu'on en trouve plus et puis
d'autre part parce que nous sommes
toujours logés petitement il est
difficile d'apprendre à quelqu'un vu le
peu de place vu tout ce que ça peut
occasionner comme perte de marchandise
perdre de temps et dans notre métier il
faut produire au maximum étant donné
qu'on a beaucoup de travail
manuel beaucoup plus que de machine
pourquoi est-ce que les cordonneries
ferment bah ell ferment parce que d'une
part où les cordonniers prennent leur
retraite ou Meur avant l'âge et qu' a
aucun jeune qui est là pour prendre
lève toutes les écoles quasiment ferment
les unes aprè les autres par manque
d'élèves dans notre corporation est-ce
que c'est un métier
d'avenir peut-être mais il faudra que
les jeunes qui se dirigent dans ce
métier soient aidés au départ s'ils
veulent l'arriver à percer qu' soit
patient parce que on ne fait pas une
clientèle en 6 mois de
temps y